Trump has no bottle he is literally
I don't think they're full they're not
if you thought how he treated Christian
the rest of these cats in 16 no he has
no bottom he will obliterate
the party and the problem is his core
supporters
they're wrong with him I think he would
do a third party challenge if he doesn't
win the nomination that ego is that
unbelievably crazy because for him I
gotta destroy you of course he ain't
thinking party they got they gotta
absolutely they gotta they you got a
little bit of trump
first of all is he kind of like he wrote
first of all if I had hell no first of
all when I sat there in the White House
tell me you don't like read harder to
deal like five six times a year because
he didn't write it
um he didn't write it and we and we now
we know he damn sure lied about the
value of all his damn properties but but
even in the White House when he met with
t-ban because I was sitting here going
this is an idiot he's sitting with a lot
of damn power man you admire him this
much are you out of your mind look first
okay this is a true story he walks in
ain't no normally the president walks in
everybody stands up everybody moves this
way I always like that scene out of The
Simpsons like I went
so I like how I backed up I was sitting
I'm like well he got to come this way
anyway I'm like I'm not walking to him
so he's shaking hands I'm like
I can't call this son of a [__] Mr
President
then I went
hell I can't call him mister
so now I'm standing like what the hell
am I gonna call this dude no he's he was
that's crazy no he has the man has the
man has no character that's crazy no no
no no no no no no I don't I told you
point blank when you show who you are I
don't want evil around me and when he
walked up to me I went
hi you think he's evil oh hell yes wow
that man is absolutely evil when you
when you will
the people who you work with yeah how
you will destroy them how you will treat
them that man is that man is pure trash
but the people who care about the power
oh first of all you look at Christy I'm
like dude you kissed his ass so much and
he still talked about your weight blew
you off I mean just just dismissed you
and they kept coming out for more more
beats who do you think who do you think
if you had to if you had to ruin right
now pick who would be the number one
Democratic person because I don't know
about I don't believe in the Biden I
don't think because they're openly
trying to just destroy him right now
with all these like who who's running
who would you say would be though the
number two guy then you can't here's it
again if you had to if you had to guess
I'm gonna say what I've said in the
previous elections the reason you can't
even just throw it out there
so many things change
who is the most I would say the most
effective Communicator is Buddha judge
what's going to happen you're a small
town mayor dude
it's gonna be held against you okay like
it not him being gay it's gonna be held
a gift about some people it's a fact
right so then you go well you got
Gretchen Whitman who's the governor of
Michigan who Biden was that close to
picking as his VP all right uh and so
you've got other people out there but
the problem is and this is the thing
about when you run
you can look great on paper
you can have all the right it's like
hiring a candidate oh my God it's hire
this person and they get in the building
and you're like
who the hell is this person like what
happened to the person we interviewed
so Fred Thompson remember when he ran oh
my God
Reagan again
boys
they would he was the worst campaigner
ever dudes in Iowa wanted to watch the
Tennessee football game he didn't want
to go shake hands it was awful
campaigns expose
everything about you and again you're
great on paper so Obama
Obama everybody forgets everybody
forgets Obama was down 20 points to
Hillary in October of 2007. everybody
forgets that
he could he was not breaking through
until she screwed up the question about
the uh driver's licenses for uh legal
immigrants at the debate uh in Iowa
that's what cracked the door open
Trump he's not going to win
Biden oh nowhere in the hell Joe's gonna
win so think about it conventional
wisdom means nothing because the voters
at a certain period of time see things
totally different in conventional wisdom
simply could not predict any of that so
who looks great right now
gets grinded in that system and so you
just gotta go through 23 but I think
absolutely barring anything health-wise
Biden's running
he's the president he controls the
apparatus and if you and if you try to
run against him you're going to get
screwed because bottom line is the
apparatus gonna say what the hell are
you doing you got to raise money you got
to have votes and that's just not going
to happen I just think again anything
health-wise he's gonna be the nominee
and I'll be talking about Karma's not
gonna be the Bible yes you will it's
going to be Biden Harris again barring
anything Health got you it's Biden
Harris they got to live with it yeah
he's gonna be 82 but the bottom line is
hey
that's what happened when you look
somebody who's 78. you didn't say
anything about Newsome no Gavin Gavin
okay why didn't I say Gavin Newsom
Gavin Newsom is not going to run it will
be political suicide
suicide why would you say that I'm just
curious because he he can't win but but
assume assume suicide assume Biden does
have a health issue or maybe something
it is wide open that is why it also then
Newsome has no no if Biden has a health
issue right that's what I'm asking the
race is wide open will vice president
Kamal Harris Run apps this is if Biden
has a health issue and he announces I'm
not seeking re-election the Democratic
race is wide open there is no will
Newsom jump in yes will Buddha Joe jump
in yes will vice president Harris jump
in yes will Whitmer likely jump in yes
potentially Shapiro the governor of
Pennsylvania yes uh I think Wes Moore
and Shapiro are probably being they'll
be too young they'll be barely into
their uh governorship but oh no folks
are going to run
but he clears the debt right now
but health-wise it's wide open got you
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]